[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il va donner tous les trophées du jour
ça va mon bébé c'est vrai vous merci des
statues magnifique ce jour dit je vais
te dire si tu as vu des cheveux tu en as
même pas besoin tu es beau comme ça au
c'est trop c'est trop
merci l'étoffé des impôts n'ont jamais
jamais ces infâmes de demande à janvier
chez une amie on va en parler avec
jean-michel alors bonsoir j'ai dessiné
les vidéos c'est gentil merci beaucoup
souvent je décide de remettre des
lauriers à la plus grande émission de
télé de tous les temps c'est qui alors
c'est pas ce plh avec estelle denis je
parle bien sûr de touche pas à mon poste
évidemment si vous avez toutes les
qualités série vous êtes généreux est
sensible et vous avez une barbe si bien
taillée que valérie bénaïm on est
jalouse and order mais vous avez un des
gros défauts évidemment c'est que vous
adorez vous moquer des chroniqueurs et
j'en ai fait les frais vous me traitez
souvent de tarbes à mais vous vous êtes
pas mal non plus cyril hanouna je vous
remets le laurier du patron qui est
passé de baba à tarbes abba dureté de la
pole dance mais jamais trop copié voire
bien à fixer comme dans mes sorties me
va très bien merci à vous et moi mais tu
as bien juste apprendre à cédric 6r qui
viendra nous voir je sais que la
véritable oui on terminera l'émission
avec lui et il est chez le coiffeur ils
arrivent
vous avez ce cas dans les boîtes vous
vous savez pas non je le découvre par
contre je jusqu'à dans votre cerveau
[Rires]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
chaque semaine on fera le trajet cette
chronique c'est parce je vous le dit qui
aime bien châtie bien évidemment alors
c'est vous savez que beaucoup rêvent
d'être chroniqueur et pro et c'est une
amie sa fondation c'est notre 15 ans
vous savez que beaucoup rêvent d'être
chronique en touche pas à mon poste
et pour être embauché par vous faut
remplir des critères indispensables à ne
rien connaître en télé et de deux
bafouillé à chaque phrase je décerne
donc à cyril hanouna le laurier du gars
qui n'emploie que des mecs qui ne savent
pas aligner trois mots sans ripper c'est
un des rares qui semble pas tellement
atteint et ce sans que sa censure pas
tant que ça c'est évidemment une manière
de faire le buzz le beurre martine aubry
ce qui est choquant se prend pas au top
mais d'autres infos la ferme célébrités
en afrique ce pas vous mentir ça a été
un désastre questionnaire sur sur google
sondages et il nous ne sommes pas
quelles sont nos épreuves les épreuves
qui font peur mais prenons les épreuves
dont on a envie de faire et si
simplement on a on est bon on hache ou
pas c'est vrai que là ce côté là sans
rigoler sans nom mais ce côté c'est un
égal à problèmes non mais il échoue il
est toujours chaud avant ça devient
froid sec devraient aussi quelques
petits soucis de ponctualité
par exemple touche pas à mon poste se
termine quand lé matin comment surfer ma
chronique vous faites comme livraison
darty ya des créneaux j'aurais passe
entre 19h et 23h alors bon tp peau qui
fera des problèmes de régis que soit à
cause du sceau de lancement de vidéo
mais la régie s'est dit tiens qu'est ce
qu'on pourrait faire pour énerver un peu
plus le patron ils ont prouvé
on pourrait par exemple lui dire que ne
pas lui dire que l'émission a démarré et
qu'il est à l'antenne ça se fait
beaucoup ces derniers vrais c'est
extraordinaire alors c'est encore assez
encore arrivé ce soir
alors voici donc évidemment le laurier
de l'émission qui sait jamais quand elle
finie mais qui sait pas non plus quand
elle commence
alors lundi vous êtes tranquillement en
train de discuter quand vous comprenez
que vous êtes à l'antenne quelques jours
avant vous êtes en train d'envoyer des
sms à christophe beaugrand quand vous
apprenez vous êtes à l'antenne
[Musique]
excuse moi
tais toi donc là donc là on à l'antenne
et quand c'est encore reproduits vous
avez voulu trouver un coupable
ce sera eric notre chauffeur de salle je
crois qu'on a on à l'antenne et mac un
chinois c'est pas toi de données
hautement masisi mrdja siamu un budget
[Rires]
alors ça fait déjà presque non que
christine kelly est arrivé dans touche
pas à mon poste très un an de mariage
c'est les noces de coton parler dans
benjamin castaldi n'est jamais allé
jusqu'à un an un mois de mariage c'est
les noces de polystyrène
alors notre casting c'est une petite
biche mais qui peut très vite se
transforme en scorpion well pourquoi la
feria schlak écrit attention là c'est
une kelly je vous décerne le laurier de
la meuf qui est passé du csa à mpm
tu es vraiment estime kelly elle
s'affirme pas si elle a proposé
plusieurs dizaines de millions d'euros
pour une seringue dans merde c'est pas
possible on va raconter parce que je
suis allé voir l'assemblée nationale la
semaine dernière j'appelle à raconter
encore moins d'un faux jadwa patrick
sébastien c'est comme un mythomane
non mais c'est pas une je peux finir ma
phrase si tu permets et je m'emmerde
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]